Now, this building had to receive
two and a half thousand really highly strung thoroughbred horses
that were coming off long-haul flights,
highly jet-lagged, not feeling their finest.
And the problem the engineer confronted was,
what quantity of waste to cater for?
Now, you don't get taught this in engineering school -- (Laughter) --
and it's not really the kind of thing you want to get wrong,
so he could have spent months talking to vets, doing the research,
tweaking the spreadsheet.
Instead, he asked for help
and he found someone who had designed the Jockey Club in New York.
The problem was solved in less than a day.
Arup believes that the culture of helpfulness
is central to their success.
Now, helpfulness sounds really anemic,
but it's absolutely core to successful teams,
and it routinely outperforms individual intelligence.
Helpfulness means I don't have to know everything,
I just have to work among people who are good at getting and giving help.
At SAP, they reckon that you can answer any question in 17 minutes.
But there isn't a single high-tech company I've worked with
that imagines for a moment that this is a technology issue,
because what drives helpfulness is people getting to know each other.
Now that sounds so obvious, and we think it'll just happen normally,
but it doesn't.
When I was running my first software company,
I realized that we were getting stuck.
There was a lot of friction, but not much else,
and I gradually realized the brilliant, creative people that I'd hired
didn't know each other.
They were so focused on their own individual work,
they didn't even know who they were sitting next to,
and it was only when I insisted that we stop working
and invest time in getting to know each other
that we achieved real momentum.
Now, that was 20 years ago, and now I visit companies
that have banned coffee cups at desks
because they want people to hang out around the coffee machines
and talk to each other.
The Swedes even have a special term for this.
They call it fika, which means more than a coffee break.
It means collective restoration.
At Idexx, a company up in Maine,
they've created vegetable gardens on campus so that people
from different parts of the business
can work together and get to know the whole business that way.
Have they all gone mad?
Quite the opposite -- they've figured out that when the going gets tough,
and it always will get tough
if you're doing breakthrough work that really matters,
what people need is social support,
and they need to know who to ask for help.
Companies don't have ideas; only people do.
And what motivates people
are the bonds and loyalty and trust they develop between each other.
What matters is the mortar,
not just the bricks.
Now, when you put all of this together,
what you get is something called social capital.
Social capital is the reliance and interdependency that builds trust.
The term comes from sociologists who were studying communities
that proved particularly resilient in times of stress.
Social capital is what gives companies momentum,
and social capital is what makes companies robust.
What does this mean in practical terms?
It means that time is everything,
because social capital compounds with time.
So teams that work together longer get better, because it takes time
to develop the trust you need for real candor and openness.
And time is what builds value.
When Alex Pentland suggested to one company
that they synchronize coffee breaks
so that people would have time to talk to each other,
profits went up 15 million dollars,
and employee satisfaction went up 10 percent.
Not a bad return on social capital,
which compounds even as you spend it.
Now, this isn't about chumminess, and it's no charter for slackers,
because people who work this way tend to be kind of scratchy,
impatient, absolutely determined to think for themselves
because that's what their contribution is.
Conflict is frequent because candor is safe.
And that's how good ideas turn into great ideas,
because no idea is born fully formed.
It emerges a little bit as a child is born,
kind of messy and confused, but full of possibilities.
And it's only through the generous contribution, faith and challenge
that they achieve their potential.
And that's what social capital supports.
Now, we aren't really used to talking about this,
about talent, about creativity, in this way.
We're used to talking about stars.
So I started to wonder, well, if we start working this way,
does that mean no more stars?
So I went and I sat in on the auditions
at the Royal Academy of Dramatic Art in London.
And what I saw there really surprised me,
because the teachers weren't looking for individual pyrotechnics.
They were looking for what happened between the students,
because that's where the drama is.
And when I talked to producers of hit albums,
they said, "Oh sure, we have lots of superstars in music.
It's just, they don't last very long.
It's the outstanding collaborators who enjoy the long careers,
because bringing out the best in others is how they found the best
in themselves."
And when I went to visit companies that are renowned
for their ingenuity and creativity,
I couldn't even see any superstars,
because everybody there really mattered.
And when I reflected on my own career,
and the extraordinary people I've had the privilege to work with,
I realized how much more we could give each other
if we just stopped trying to be superchickens.
(Laughter) (Applause)
Once you appreciate truly how social work is,
a lot of things have to change.
Management by talent contest has routinely pitted
employees against each other.
Now, rivalry has to be replaced by social capital.
For decades, we've tried to motivate people with money,
even though we've got a vast amount of research that shows
that money erodes social connectedness.
Now, we need to let people motivate each other.
And for years, we've thought that leaders were heroic soloists who were expected,
all by themselves, to solve complex problems.
Now, we need to redefine leadership
as an activity in which conditions are created
in which everyone can do their most courageous thinking together.
We know that this works.
When the Montreal Protocol called for the phasing out of CFCs,
the chlorofluorocarbons implicated in the hole in the ozone layer,
the risks were immense.
CFCs were everywhere,
and nobody knew if a substitute could be found.
But one team that rose to the challenge adopted three key principles.
The first was the head of engineering, Frank Maslen, said,
there will be no stars in this team.
We need everybody.
Everybody has a valid perspective.
Second, we work to one standard only:
the best imaginable.
And third, he told his boss, Geoff Tudhope,
that he had to butt out,
because he knew how disruptive power can be.
Now, this didn't mean Tudhope did nothing.
He gave the team air cover,
and he listened to ensure that they honored their principles.
And it worked: Ahead of all the other companies tackling this hard problem,
this group cracked it first.
And to date, the Montreal Protocol
is the most successful international environmental agreement
ever implemented.
There was a lot at stake then,
and there's a lot at stake now,
and we won't solve our problems if we expect it to be solved
by a few supermen or superwomen.
Now we need everybody,
because it is only when we accept that everybody has value
that we will liberate the energy and imagination and momentum we need
to create the best beyond measure.
Thank you.
(Applause)